Evet akademisyen olarak her zaman bu
kadar güzel bir kalabalığa konuşma şansı
elde etmiyoruz geldiğiniz için
teşekkürler bir akademisyenim aynı
zamanda bir mucidim e laboratuvarda bizi
en çok motive eden şey icat çıkarmak
benim çalıştığım alan da sensör
teknolojileri ve yeni ekran yani Display
teknolojileri sensör teknolojileri
deyince evdeki alarm geliyor belki
aklınıza ama Eee aynı şekilde Display
teknolojisi deyince belki televizyon
geliyor Bunun Esasında Çok daha ötesinde
bugün akıllı cep telefonları e
sensörlerin en büyük müşterisi bir
telefonun içerisinde onlarca sensör var
işte akselerometre vesair Esi aynı
şekilde ekran teknolojileri için için de
e retinal Display diyoruz mesela retina
çözünürlüğü gösteren displayer ya da
yeni ekranlar geliyor mesela bunlar
aslında teknolojideki en büyük
yenilikleri kullananlar Eee Cep
telefonlarından biraz bahsedersek
bunlarda Mekandan bağımsız olarak aşağı
yukarı her işimizi yapmak mümkün fakat
yapamadığımız şeyler de var mesela
Gelecekte bizi neler bekliyor onlardan
bahsedeceğim yapamadığımız şeyler
Örneğin TED konferansında birisiyle
tanıştınız işte telefonumu çıkartayım
Google'dan bir bakayım profili neymiş
Ondan sonra Konuşmaya başlayayım
Networking yapmak için demiyoruz veya
yabancı bir ülkedeyken işte anında bize
tercümeyi yapan akıllı kulaklıklar henüz
yok Olsaydı çok güzel olurdu diğer
birçok şey film izlerken Efendim Yazı
yazarken dokümanları bir araya getirip
bir sürü karmaşık işler yaparken Tasarım
yaparken büyük ekranlara ihtiyacımız var
Bunları esasında yapabilecek
teknolojiler var ve geliyor bugün size
giyilebilir ekran teknolojilerin
hikayesini ve bizim bu konularda neler
yaptığımızı anlatacağım Bilişim
teknolojisindeki eğilimlere bakarsak
sosyal medya Bulut Bilişim şeylerin
interneti denilen her türlü elektrikli
aletin internet bağlantısının olması ve
büyük data konusundan bahsedebiliriz
büyük data da nereden çıktı D derseniz
Aslında Bunun sorumlusu bizleriz mesela
şu anda kimse resim çekmiyor ama ben
ünlü birisi olsaydım işte fotoğraflarımı
videolarımı çekip paylaşıyor olacaktınız
bir anda Eee sürekli ivmelenen artan bir
datayı internete koyuyoruz ve Buradan da
samanlıkta iine aramak gibi Eee arayıp
aradığımızı bulmaya çalışıyoruz veya
şeylerin interneti dediğimiz gerçek le
şeye başladıkça da şu anda hiç farkında
bile olmadığımız birtakım bilgiler
Örneğin İstanbul'da acaba kaç kişi ekmek
kızartıyor şu anda gibi gereksiz görünen
bize ama üreticiler için önemli bilgiler
ulaşma şansımız olacak
Eee Biz de esasında burada şöyle
düşünüyor olabilirsiniz bunları Aslında
tetikleyen Akıllı telefonlar çıktı
appler gelişti işte donanım Aslında esas
sorumlusu bu teknolojiyi tekleyen Eee
donanımdaki gelişmeler ve her şeyin
küçülmesi y bunun arkasında yatan
mikroelektronik mikr mekanik ve mikro
Optik teknolojilerindeki gelişmeler
diyebilirim Biz de tam bu alanda
çalışıyoruz O yüzden çok şanslıyız icat
çıkarmamız daha kolay oluyor E bu
küçülme sayesinde olanlardan bir tanesi
3 sene önceki işte bilgisayarla bugünkü
akıllı telefon veya 2 sene sonra çıkacak
akıllı saat aşağı yukarı aynı işlemciye
aynı yeteneklere sahipler fakat e 2015
mesela akıllı saatlerin yılı olacağı
söyleniyor Belki bir kısmınız akıllı
saatler kullanmaya başladılar fakat
ekran çok küçük yani Yani oradan bakarak
bir şeyler yapmak gerçekten zor Ben
mesela bunun çok geleceğin teknolojisin
akıllı saat türü şeylerde olduğuna
inanmıyorum yani sağlık gibi uygulamalar
çok güzel ama küçük ekranlardan dolayı
Bunun sebebi de benim tahminim bizim
çocuklarımız diyecekler ki ya babamın
akıllı dediği bir tane saati varmış İşte
bütün gün bit gibi ekran bit kadar
yazıları okuyup mesajlaşmaya
çalışıyormuş ve her gece de şarja
takması gerekiyormuş veya arkadaşı da
diyecek ki benim dedemin saat diye bir
şey taşıyormuş işte kolunda sürekli tek
yaptığı zamanı gö
göstermiş yüzlerce yıldır belki Aslında
tek yaptığı zamanı göstermek olan bir
saat vardı şimdi akıllı saatlere gidişat
oldu Peki bundan sonra neler
olacak gelecekte insan bilgisayar
etkilemiş ile ilgili benim öngörüler
göstermek istiyorum bir tanesi bize ait
mesela Avatar sanal bulum ya da
telepresence robotları bizim yerimize
Mesela biz plajda dinlenirken aynı anda
iki yerde olmak isteyebiliriz Belki bir
toplantıya katılacak Veya bizim yerimize
müzeyi Gezebilir müze gezmek de zevkli
bir şey ama İki işi aynı anda yapmak
isteyebiliriz diğer bir tanesi azınlık
raporunda olduğu gibi büyük datanın
içerisinde yüzerek şeffaf büyük
ekranlara bakarak aradığımızı bulmaya
çalışacağız belki diğer bir şey
Terminatör filminde hatırlarsınız Belki
orada olduğu gibi e gözlük şeklinde
Hatta direkt olarak Kontak lens
üzerinden gözümüze yansıtılan
teknolojiler olabilir Daha fütüristik
bir şey göstermek istersem de düşünce
gücüyle iletişim burada Aslında
metafizik düşünmeyin gerçekten e gerçek
bilimsel olarak işte beyinden
bilgisayara iletişimi Stephen Hawking
videolarından hepimiz biliyoruz Hatta
beyinden beyine iletişim konusunda da
araştırma geliştirme çalışmaları devam
ediyor Şimdi evrin ve teknoloji diye bir
şey var bu karikatürün değişik
versiyonlarını Muhtemelen hepiniz
görmüşsünüzdür işte Bilgisayar
dediğimizde karşımızda olan ve
baktığımız bir şey anlaşılıyordu biz
buna iki tane küçük ekleme yaptık Bir
tanesi bu arkadaş Muhtemelen tanıyoruz
bunu hepimiz içimizde kaç kişi her gün
bu pozu
veriyor evet teşekkürler
Bir de elini kaldırmayı da şu anda cep
telefonuna bakanlar
var peki Gelecekte nasıl olacak acaba
konuşmamın başlığında söylediğim gibi
başımızı dik yürümemizi sağlayacak
teknolojiler neler olabilir
Eee Google GL öldü diyeceksiniz belki
işte çok popülerdi birkaç yıldır fakat
Akıllı telefonlar çıktı Arkasından da
işte E bu tür sanal gerçeklik ya da Eee
artırılmış gerçeklik denilen augmented
Reality uygulamalar yönü gözlükleri
eminim çoğunuz görmeye başladınız son
yıllarda ama muhtemelen şöyle
sanıyorsunuz işte Akıllı telefonlar
çıktı hocam dediğin gibi ekranlar
küçüktü filan Şimdi göze yakın displayer
insanlar uğraşmaya başladılar esasında
böyle değil bunun hikayesi çok eskilere
dayanıyor size Bunun biraz tarihçesini
göstereyim biraz da aslında
inovasyonların böyle bir anda ortaya
çıkmadığı mesajını vermek istiyorum
Bunun ilk atası 1968 yılında Evan
sutherland yaptığı kaska takılan gözüktü
daha son Sonra işte NASA olsun askeri
olsun pilotlar için bu kaska takılan
displayer le uğraştılar daha sonra 90'lı
yıllarda birçok şirket kuruldu bu birçok
Çoğu da hayatta kalmadı battılar Ben de
1997 yılında Doktor sonrası ilk girdiğim
firmada microvision firmasında bu
işlerle uğraşmaya başlamıştım en altta
Sağdaki fotoğrafta görüyorsunuz benim
2004 yılında ilk çıkan ürünü denerken Bu
da birkaç bin tane satıldı sonra ürünle
devam edilmedi fakat teknolojinin biraz
öncesinde gidiyordu Bunlar e açıkçası
hazır değildi çünkü bu genser
teknolojileri vesaire internet altyapısı
henüz yoktu o zaman bu örnekler çok
güzel diyeceksiniz Belki ben de ilk
patentleri İşte bu teknoloji üzerine
almıştım fakat Türkiye'de neler
yapılıyor işte hep Amerika'dan
Avrupa'dan vesaire örnekler
gösteriyorsunuz diyebilirsiniz Türkiye
burada küçük bir parantez açıp Eee
ülkemizdeki durum tespitini yapmak
istiyorum şimdi böyle bir kitap buldum
bulduğumda da bayağı şaşırmıştım Osmanlı
İmparatorluğu'nun kapitalistleşme
tecrübesi ve telif haklarının gelişim mi
burada anlatıldığı üzere Osmanlı'da
telif hakkı bilinci
gelişmemiştir
şaşırma fikir ve sanat üzeri üzerindeki
özel Mülkiyet hakkı ahlaken meşru
sayılmıyor y Mesela bu kitabın çok
beğendiğim bir kapağı var ü tane ayrı
minyatürden oluşuyor bunu yapan
nakkaşlar Orhan Pamuk'un Benim adım
kırmızıda anlattığı gibi eserlerini
imzalamaz lardı eseri sipariş verenin
malı sayılırdı daha sonra o günden
bugüne Tabii ki epey yol aldık Eee fakat
yine de telif hakları ve patentler çok
da suçluluk duy ihlal ediliyor yani
çakma korsan gibi terimler dilimizde
yaygınca kullanılıyor Eee icat çıkarma
sözü de aslında ben ilk başta öyle
başlamak istedim özellikle negatif bir
şey çağrıştırıyor Halbuki biz bunu çok
tam tersi ne güzel icat şekil çıkardın
diye karşılamamız lazım çocuklar böyle
bir şey
yaptığında şimdi belki diyeceksiniz ki
Çok karamsar bir tablo çizdik ülkemiz
içinde bizde de inovasyon güzel şey
örnekleri yok mu benim laboratuvar olan
şeylerden bahsedeceğim Sırf benim
laboratuvar çıkan 30 kadar Eee patent
dediğimiz teknoloji var Farklı farklı
konularda ben sadece displayer
bahsediyorum bugün Eee bunlardan 20
tanesi de öğrencilerin de bizzat
bazıları Hatta lisans öğrencisi patent
buluş sahibi olduğu icatlar
Eee Mesela şimdi Aslında bu konu e 10-15
sene önce fazla kimsenin gündeminde de
değildi belki ama bütün üniversitelerde
de işte teknoloji transfer ofisleri var
Eee değişik ödüller var hem devletten
olsun Hem Eee özel sektörden inovasyonu
özendirmek için bu mesela bizim daha
önce gösterdiğim gözlükten sonra
firmayla yaptığımız e pico projektör
teknolojisi cebimde de bunlardan bir
tane var işte cep telefonuna dedik ki Bu
akıllı cihazlar gelişiyor filan biz bu
kafaya takılan şeyden Vazgeçelim işte
cep telefonu boyutlarında Eee
projektörler yapalım mobil cihazlar daha
sonra onu yaptıktan sonra ü boyutlu
projektör yapabilir miyiz acaba diye
uğraştık bunu da yaptık çok da güzel
çalışıyor esasında şu anda bu ticari
değil ama bir önceki ticariyi fir
satılıyor Eee normal bir pasif polarize
gözlük taktığınızda gittiğiniz gibi
evinizi cep telefonuna çevirebiliyor
daha sonra acaba gözlüksüz ü boyutlu
yapabilir miyiz diye uğraştık burada ik
tane projektör var işte öğrenin gözünde
iki tane böyle ışık bandı görüyorsunuz
birisine sol gözüne birisine sağ gözüne
gitmesi gereken Işık gönderiliyor Bunlar
geldiği zaman işte ikisiyle birlikte
kafasında da gezdiği zaman bir tane
kamera var ekranın altında ekranı
döndürüyor otomatikman kişiyi takip
ediyor Daha sonra sanal bulum denilen
uygulamalarla uğraşmaya başladık Şimdi
örneklerinden göstereceğim Bir birazdan
Bu da ben aslında insan bilgisayar
etkileşiminin geleceğinin bu yönde
olacağını düşünüyorum e gözlük şeklinde
Ama küçük Gözünün bir köşesinde e cep
telefonu boyutlarında görüş açısı veren
gözlükler değil de gerçekten büyük işte
bir gözünüzde Hatta iki gözünüze
isterseniz farklı şey gösterirsiniz
isterseniz önünü perde gibi böyle
kapatarak Eee kendinizi daha içerisine
alan Eee sanal gerçeklik uygulamalarına
bakabilirsiniz veya üç boyutlu
yapabilirsiniz sol ve sağ göze farklı
şeyler yaparak solla sağa farklı
verdiğinizde de bu da yeterli değil
Şimdi Bu animasyonda gördüğünüz Eee Biz
bununla ilgili büyük bir tane proje
aldık Eee yapmaya çalışım dünyadaki ilk
holografik gerçek üç boyutlu derinlik
algısı veren holografik gözlüğü
yapıyoruz ve oldukça ilerleme kaydettik
Bu konuda da holografik demek de normal
sinemaya gittiğinizde Aslında gözünüzün
odağı daima ekranda fakat Siz kendinize
yakın bir şey var sanıyorsunuz uzun süre
boyunca gözünüzün odağını değiştirmeden
işte beyniniz Ama yakında bir şey var
algılıyor bu baş ağrısı mide bulanması
vesaire yapıyor gerçek bir derinlik
algısı da vermiyor halog grafik
teknolojilerde ise baktığınız şey net
görünüyor sadece Eee Bu da bizim şu anki
en büyük projemiz Eee bu böyle şeyler
gerçekleştiği zaman Aslında İnsan
beynine ışığı ne kadar yakın getirsek
çünkü bütün bilgiyi Biz bilgisayardan
alıyoruz ekrandan çıkıyor gözümüzden
içeri çok az bir kısmı giriyor ışığın
Halbuki gözümüze yaklaştırdı Belki 100
kat daha Işık verimli hale geliyor daha
fazla bilgiyi En kısa yoldan
gönderebiliyoruz sesi de aynı şekilde 3
yani böylece ne olacak Belki ımx
tiyatrosuna gitmişsiniz gibi Eee
gözlüğünüzü takacaksınız ü boyutlu ses
üç boyutlu görüntü mükemmel bir şekilde
aktarılabilecek
bunun için göz takip teknolojileri çok
önemli burada da bizim üç boyutlu
yazıcıyla yaptığımız bir model göz
görüyorsunuz işte kamera dediğimiz şey
de aslında büyük bir şey değil gerçekten
gözlüğün kenarına takılan 1 mm
boyutlarında bir kamera görüyorsunuz Bu
o anda nereye baktığınızı anlayarak
görüntüyü sürekli olarak değiş
Mümkün olacak bu göz takip sistemleriyle
uğraşıyoruz başka nelerle yapıyoruz
mesela şeffaf ekranlar dedim o Tom
Cruise'un filmdeki şeyini göstermiştim
bunun esasında daha enteresan yaptık İki
taraftan baktığınız zaman aynı anda
farklı görüntüler görüyorum hem de
arkasını
görebiliyorum Burada da yaptığımız
dünyanın en büyük şeffaf cam ekranı yani
üzerinde elektrik bağlantısı yok şeffaf
bir ekran bu video oynatayım
hem arkadan geçerken
tane ben var yani bir burada sahnedeki
ben ekr arkasındaki ben bir de ekranın
üzerinde oynayan Ben Eee diğer arkasının
gayet güzel göründüğünü görüyorsunuz
üzerine video oynatabiliyor Dediğim gibi
iki taraftan farklı şekilde
gösterebiliyor Evet şimdi Eee size
sahnede Bir de
Eee gerçek olarak bir iki tane görüntüyü
göstermek istiyoruz burada Mesela
yapılabilecek şeyler ne var
arkadaşlarımı davet edeyim öğrenci
arkadaşları Eee arabanın mesela camının
tamamının böyle bir ekranla kaplanabilir
ş navigasyon ve gösterge bilgilerine
bakarken
yolcular farklı açılardan farklı
görüntüler göstereceğiz yolcular da o
anda film izleyebilecekler mesela bütün
araba ekranını Böylece araba camını
ekrana
dönüştürebilecek Bu da yani ik anlama
gelen bir sözcük Ama gerçekten kafaya
takılan
projektör şimdi Bununla ilgili tane şey
göstereceğim kull lazım tabi
Burada sizden bir ricam var Ben şu
ekranın önüne geçeceğim Öncelikle
resmimi çekmeni istiyorum ama flashlı
olsun küçük bir sürpriz var flashlı
resim çekerseniz flashsız çekerseniz ne
gördüğünüzü görüyorsunuz
da flashlar biraz Patlamaya başladı
flashlı çektiğiniz zaman ne oldu beni
pek göremiyorsunuz değil mi ekran
parlıyor burada özel bir ekran var
normal bir perdeden bahsetmiyoruz çok
güzel ünlü gibi hissetmiş oldum Ben de
şimdi
Eee kameradan görüntüyü alabiliyor
muyuz
Eee çok az gecikmeyle geliyor
ama geldi
mi Heh tamam şimdi eee Burada da
kendinizi görüyorsunuz
ekranda Bu açıdan baktığım zaman
esasında
e fazla bir şey görmemek le birlikte bu
manken arkadaş Ne izliyor Ona bakarsak
Mesela bu bir tane film izliyor
görünüyor değil
mi bunun bakış açısından işte
filmin bitişine denk geldik biraz yavaş
kalınca ama tekrar
dönerim Fakat aynı anda bu buradaki kişi
ise işte Koç Üniversitesi'nin
helikopterden çekilmiş bir görüntüsünü
izliyor
Şimdi mesela Havaalanı gibi bir yerde bu
kafaya takılan projektörü çıkartıp aynı
anda aynı ekranı paylaşarak bir sürü
kişi çalışma ortamı yaratabilir bir
yandan da işte gözünüzün önüne bir şey
kapatıp kendinizi dünyadan
soyutlamanın döneriz diğer bir göstermek
istediğimiz de Selim sana vereyim şimdi
Bizim okulumuzda bana başlamadan Eee Tıp
Fakültesi kuruldu onun kurulmasıyla
birlikte farklı daha disiplinler arası
çalışmalar yapmaya başladık Mesela bir
damla kandan bir sürü hastalık tanısı
yapan bir cihaz geliştiriyoruz başka bir
uygulamada parkinson hastaları için
kulaktan simülasyon vererek Bir nevi
modern akupunktur teknolojisiyle Eee bu
el titremelerine durduran bir
teknolojiyle uğraşıyoruz diğer bir
yaptığımız şey de son icatlarımız Zan
diyeyim Eee röntgen teknolojisi Şimdi
iki tane laboratuvarımız bel kemiği
Selim ölçer yardımcı oluyor Bütün
demoları da hazırlanmasına yardımcı oldu
Ulaş adı yen Doktor öğrencim Onur Onur
Çakmak da doktor öğrencimdi i gün önce
Doktor oldu Doktor Onur Buyurun
gösterin
gel şimdi en son böyle bir şey
yaptığımda ilkokulda kızımın sınıf Akşam
eve gittiğinde çocuk beni sihirbaz geldi
sınıfa diye
anlatmışlar Yani bu son gösterdiğimizde
küçük bir sihir vardı Selim şeyi
gösterir misin Eee cep telefonu
ekranında ne gördüğümüzü
Eee gösterdiğimiz her şey gerçek
akademisyen ve araştırmacı olarak
hatırlanmak istiyorum siirbaz olarak
değil ülkemizde de güzel şeyler
yapılıyor Benim laboratuar bu güzel
örneklerden bir tanesi Teşekkürler
İlginiz
[Alkış]
için
for